[Musique]
le 24 février 2022
en s'attaquant à l'Ukraine au mépris des
droits de son peuple Vladimir Poutine a
lancé un terrible conflit qui marque le
retour de la guerre sur le sol européen
la guerre en Ukraine c'est au moins 7000
civils ukrainiennes morts et 11000
blessés c'est 8 millions du crinien
obligé de fuir leur pays ce sont des
villes entières bombardées et rasées par
les forces militaires
en ce 24 février 2023
nous pensons à toutes les Ukrainiennes
et tous les Ukrainiens victimes de la
folie de Vladimir Poutine
son fantasme d'intégrisme national
[Musique]
dès le début de cette invasion l'Union
européenne s'est mobilisé
la France s'est tenue aux côtés de
l'Ukraine
pour défendre nos valeurs démocratiques
et défendre un peuple entier dans un
conflit si proche de nous
parce que leur combat est pleinement le
nôtre nous avons accueilli plus de 120
000 réfugiés
le Mouvement Démocrate adore et déjà
apporté son soutien par une compagne de
don à destination des ukrainiennes et
des Ukrainiens restaient dans leur pays
nos militants se sont mobilisés en 2022
et continueront de l'être jusqu'à la fin
du conflit
en cette tragique date anniversaire nous
sommes au côté de chaque personne
réfugiés combattant blessé enfant enlevé
à leurs parents
les crimes de guerre des forces armées
russes ne resteront pas impuni
continuons à soutenir l'Ukraine et son
peuple
[Musique]